every day around 50 000 people in
england test positive for covid19
the highest number in six months and
rising fast
most a young unvaccinated fit enough to
survive
but not all 277 people died last week
and among the vulnerable
so-called freedom day brings little more
than anxiety
there's a lot of concerning information
coming out which show
rising hospitalizations in the uk rising
case numbers
the attendant concerns of the rising
numbers of people suffering from
long-covered symptoms in this country
but also just in the last 24 hours or so
we're starting to hear from
doctors that nhs services are starting
to have clinics
and services cancelled because of the
high rates of staff sickness
and isolation that's needing to happen
it's a small mercy then that the schools
will close in a few days time
more than eight hundred children were
sent home last week because someone in a
year group
bubble tested positive many will begin
their summer break
in isolation parents will worry about
the ongoing risk of infection
i won't give up the mask and nor my
children or my husband we won't we will
wear the mask because i can't see
really a nice and clear
future in the next months
to wear them or not to wear them masks
are a question the government has
wrestled with
but without conclusive answers they'll
no longer be required by
law but most offices shops and transport
companies will continue to encourage
them
and there's this the national health
service app pinging away
incessantly telling hundreds of
thousands of people to self-isolate each
week because
a close contact has tested positive and
each ping means
income lost staff shortages holiday
plans
in ruins there is some good news singing
is back
banned since the start of the pandemic
and a chorus of
full-throated approval for that for
people who sing whether you sing as an
amateur or a professional
it's it's a very important part of your
life it's a way of keeping your sanity
and keeping your relationship to the
world
and so for us to be able to finally get
together and hear sound around us not
just coming out of a few speakers in
front of our computer
it's just been revelatory it means
churches nightclubs and theaters can
roar back into life
freed also from social distancing rules
but will there be people brave enough to
fill them
it may be called freedom day for some
jonah but in fact
for the prime minister and his finance
minister one wonders whether
to a certain extent they might have shot
themselves in the foot by sort of
singing the praises of freedom day
well you know the government's rationale
in in the words of prime minister boris
johnson is if not now
uh when if you wait as the scientists
are urging uh for more people to be
vaccinated uh there are always going to
be gaps uh
in that vaccine program vulnerabilities
within it
uh well then you risk the the
possibility of a higher peak later of
the year going to the winter a difficult
time for the nhs
anyway they don't want to have to do
that you would also be missing out on
the summer the natural
fire break as he called it of the
schools being off uh preventing
wider spread infections there and all
the while you've noticed in the
government messaging here it's become
ever
less gung-ho ever more uh
tempered frankly quite confusing people
are being told to go out and live their
lives but to do so with maximum
caution exercising personal
responsibility
and on that point you raised their with
the hundreds of thousands of people
being pinged into isolation every week
include now boris johnson himself the
prime minister
rishi sunak the secretary treasury
secretary
and indeed the health secretary sajid
javid who's actually got the virus these
are
the three most senior arguably
government figures
in fighting covid all will be watching
the so-called
celebration of freedom day tightly
locked up inside their homes
jonah for the latest thanks very much
joining us from our london
broadcast center dipty ingur dasani is a
clinical epidemiologist and senior
lecturer
at queen mary university in london she
says lifting restrictions could lead to
more mutations
that can be more dangerous this is not a
virus that we can live with i mean
um we are seeing this virus evolve
and lead to a new highly transmissible
wage every few months then
which then takes over across the world
and leads to another surge
the only way to prevent this sort of
virus adaptation and protect our
precious vaccine resources
is to prevent transmission and that's
not just a regional level
but in a global level we know that many
countries don't have adequate
access to vaccines yet and it'll be a
long time perhaps even one or two years
before everyone is vaccinated
and in that period of time if we allow
transmission to continue at high levels
we will see many many more new variants
and one could potentially escape
vaccines more fully which could have
implications for the pandemic across the
globe so i think countries need to think
carefully about
not just um you know vaccination
strategies but
also how to keep transmission low with
good surveillance test rates isolate
systems
and uh you know good uh measures to deal
with aerosol transmission like
investment and ventilation
indoor environments and masking and good
border controls
until we all get this under control
what's happened now is we've had a
highly transmissible strain emerge which
has threatened
elimination in areas that haven't had
transmission for long periods of time
like vietnam
and that's what's really concerning and
if we continue to live with this virus
we're going to see more and more
transmissible strains and at some point
elimination is going to become
impossible and they may also
keep ahead of our vaccines which means
even with vaccines we may not be able to
protect ourselves
and that will be a really dangerous
place to be